hi and welcome to cloud on air live
webinars from Google cloud hosted every
Tuesday my name is Elise Roche and I
work around data for social and
environmental impact I'm Jake poor way
the founder executive director of data
kind and we're here today to talk to you
about leveraging data science for social
change as a quick note you can ask
questions throughout the webinar on the
platform as we have Googlers on standby
ready to answer them and we'll also be
hosting a live Q&A at the end of the
presentation so with that let's get
started that's good
so another way to express the idea of
data science for social change is data
for good which is interdisciplinary
movement where private companies are
working with nonprofit organizations
NGOs and also i ji OHS in order to apply
big data solutions to real world
challenges and this has been going on
for quite some time a couple of
highlights include back in 2008 the CDC
collaborated with Google to launch
Google Flu Trends under the idea that if
you could actually track online searches
you would you know potentially be able
to predict the prevalence of a flu
outbreak later in 2011 the United
Nations global pulse initiative
advocated for a data Philanthropy
movement where private companies could
actually donate or share data to advance
humanitarian causes and in 2013 the UN
also utilized satellite imagery in order
to provide targeted disaster relief by
comparing pre and post disaster imagery
to determine which communities needed
emergency relief first and in 2017 just
last year the UN hosted the world's
first world data forum with a belief
that it would help to foster
collaboration between different
organizations and sectors and also
helped to achieve the 17 sustainable
development goals which comprised the
2030 agenda and in 23 2018
today there are interdisciplinary
programs and collaborations so companies
like Google cloud are working with
organizations like data kind in order to
you know bring the data for good
movement to life so I think you so
fascinating is that this is still very
young in a lot of ways too
there hasn't yet been a killer app for
social impact and
probably won't be because though groups
have started to find solutions like
these really what I think people are
learning in these first five or six
years this has been up is that
collaboration is really the key
technologists don't always know exactly
what to build social organizations don't
have the tech skills and so I think this
last point here is so critical that for
all the cool whiz-bang solutions were
seeing collaboration interdisciplinary
work is really key to this movement
growing absolutely so what does Google
cloud doing in the data for good
movement well since 2008 we have sought
to empower nonprofits by offering
essentially integrated solutions for
them to access starting with Google
Earth outreach allowing them to
essentially bring their stories to life
using premium Maps API x' and geo tools
with g suite for nonprofits also
nonprofits are able to work and
collaborate together with productivity
tools using Gmail and Docs at no charge
and also GCP public datasets which
actually helps to democratize access to
planetary scale datasets provided by
organizations like the World Bank the
EPA and NOAA just to name a few and now
anyone can essentially query that data
up to one terabyte per month for free
and last but not least there's cattle
and their data science for good events
which allows nonprofits to host an
online event and to tap into the
community of over 1.5 million data
scientists in order to apply Big Data
solutions to real world problems and in
addition to that we're exploring working
with nonprofit organizations and a
hands-on capacity like with data kind so
back in April we actually worked at them
around their ecosystem event at the
Skoll World Forum for social
entrepreneurship where we discussed the
potential of applying big data solutions
to real world challenges and the
humanitarian sector and also worked with
nonprofits to help scope potential data
analytics projects for future
engagements and in addition to that just
a couple of weeks ago we hosted one of
their data dives which is a weekend long
problem-solving event at the Google in
New York City office which is actually
where we're streaming from today and
we'll get into that a bit more detail
later on in the presentation but before
we dive in there wanted to rewind and
actually talk about data kind who they
are and what they stand for
thanks Elise so a little background on
data kindness that we're a nonprofit
dedicated to harnessing the power of
data science and AI in the service of
humanity and the organization really
arose from experiencing lots of data
scientists machine learning folks AI
engineers who clearly wanted to give
back but didn't exactly know how at the
same time realizing that social
organizations are a wash and data I mean
we all are right there's digital
information popping off of our cell
phones and our laptops and so we have
these new opportunities to learn more
about our world in ourselves than ever
before and so really we thought the best
way to do that was not just to have
industry building what it's building
with with data science and machine
learning but finding ways to get those
same tools into the hands of people
working in social impact whether those
are governments or nonprofits or anyone
else dedicated to seeing a better world
and as a data scientist myself it
started just by talking to a few folks
and saying hey does anyone else want to
work with some nonprofits and being very
surprised to find that not only did
people in my own friend group want to do
it but we had thousands of people around
the world writing and saying hey I want
to do this to nonprofits and governments
raising their hands and saying we want
to be part of the data for good movement
so that's how the organization started
and we run it a lot like Doctors Without
Borders for data geeks we just get folks
who want to volunteer and give their
time back to work and build solutions
alongside nonprofits in the last six
years we've done about 250 projects
we've got about 18,000 folks signed up
as volunteers and a bunch of communities
running data kind versions in their own
cities as volunteer chapters so I'm very
excited to see this data for good
movement growing immensely over the last
couple of years it'll give me just a few
quick examples of what some of the
projects look like so one was a project
we did with the American Red Cross
they're a fantastic organization and one
of the challenges they're trying to
solve was how to stop preventable fires
so there's a problem where if a fire
goes off and people don't have a smoke
alarm in their home or in their
buildings they can get hurt or worse
they can die cuz they can't get out so
the Red Cross decided we're gonna put
millions of smoke alarms for free around
the country the question was where do
they start where should you put these so
we teamed them up with some data
scientists who combined their data about
fire data along with publicly available
data from community housing data
or open data others had made available
to build a predictive model that said
look these are the places where if you
put smoke alarms they're going to be
most effective for saving lives you can
see that little map on the slide shows
the areas where they thought there would
be the most fires the most folks that
could be benefited from this so now the
Red Cross has intelligence to say here's
where we can go to focus our limited
resources and they're now saving
hundreds of lives per month with this
algorithm so that's one great example
another example about a group trying to
figure out where to use their limited
resources is with the molten eagle Water
District now they give water to folks
all across Southern California and their
job depends on being able to predict how
much demand there is and the stakes are
high because if they're wrong the only
way they have to solve this is to go
take a dump truck fill it up full of
water across town and ship it to the
people that need the water wherever it's
missing and that's a huge cost it's
environmentally destructive it's bad
thing
so some data scientists teamed up with
them and and soft they could do better
basically they built the tool that
you're seeing in that picture on the
slide which is able to predict a man to
the block by block level and now they're
not only able to get more water to
millions of people in California they've
saved over twenty five million dollars
but just saved from this shipping cost
and for being more efficient so I think
these are great examples of what can
happen when you use data science and
machine learning and prediction to help
social organizations target their
efforts more cleanly and better so that
is largely the work that was done there
but now you may ask well how does this
happen we've got a couple of different
models for how we get data scientists
together with nonprofits but one is our
data dive and data dives are like social
impact hackathons we love that
hackathons are high energy to get a lot
done but we try to modify them so that
we really made sure that by the end of
these events social organizations and
nonprofits says something that they
could use so for our data types
basically we've got three phases the
first is exploration so we worked for a
while with these nonprofits figuring out
what their problems are where the data
is what can and can't be done a lot of
organizations don't even know what's
possible at first so built that out so
we can have really clear scopes and
clear data so that in the second phase
during this sort of big event hundreds
of volunteers could show
and just start working they could hack
away at a problem they wanted we had the
nonprofits there that they could sit and
talk with and so for 48 hours they
worked on these problems so that in
stage 3 can hand off those solutions to
partners and find the groups didn't just
come up with interesting ideas or a few
creative starts like you often see in
hackathons but actually made real
progress on their goals so though the
nonprofit's could all walk away with
something that they can use so that was
basically the setup for how we work and
what we did at the day to dive and now
I'll talk a little bit about the event
itself absolutely so from the Google
cloud side we actually realized the
potential of this kind of model to drive
real world impact which is why we hosted
one of the data dives in our Google New
York City office drawing over a hundred
and thirty attendees from data
scientists to analysts designers all
passionate about defending human rights
with data and also building resilient
communities the nonprofit organizations
that we worked with over the course of
that weekend all worked around
international development projects or
defending different communities from the
harmful effects of international
development projects and these three
organizations were the inclusive
development international accountability
Council and also international
accountability project and over the
course of the weekend they're actually
able to make significant progress on the
challenges that they pose and walk away
with tangible solutions that they would
be able to then integrate immediately
into their processes which is truly
inspiring because you actually see that
you know you can sit down in a room full
of computers at the room full of very
you know talented and technical data
scientists and then take that and
immediately throw it into the real world
and have that impact and in addition to
all of that we actually had the
opportunity to host a Google Cloud
breakout session where we discussed the
currently available tools and resources
for nonprofit organizations and how they
can access them through Google for
nonprofits kaggle and also GCP public
datasets so on the projects themselves
and the nonprofit's yes let's talk about
these folks as at least mentioned
they're all in the International
Development space which means that all
these organizations are focused on
defending communities who need help
representing their rights or getting
representation when International
is happening in their area but they each
tackle a very different piece of this I
thought that was kind of interesting as
you listen to the three projects so the
first was the International
accountability project and their whole
purpose is to advocate make policy
change boost local advocacy efforts to
make sure that communities know about
every International Development project
happening around them and can act on act
on them or defend themselves when needed
now they're pretty visionary
organization I love these folks because
they're already data savvy in the sense
that they have worked really hard to
collect a whole database of every
international development project they
know of that's going on so they could
tell you right now what's going on in
Peru or in Ghana and who's responsible
for it so that's really great and
they've already done that the challenge
that they had for this weekend however
is that they were trying to understand
how they could get more updated
information about what's going on so
there are news articles or press
releases that happen around these
projects but they just go off into the
ether so it I am selves if we have this
information maybe we could have an early
warning system when we know there's
going to be a new project or when it's
going to change but what that would
require is scraping huge amounts of news
information and matching it so that's
what the volunteers said about doing
they basically scraped tons of news
articles and press releases they built
some semantic matching algorithms some
classifiers to try to understand which
projects these articles reacted to or
related to and then they pull that all
together into a one workflow that
actually now pulls that data tags it and
puts it in this database and so now I ap
is walking away with a whole API on top
of this new data model that basically
gets current events and news media into
their system so they can act more
effectively now this allows them to get
ahead of the changes get communities
ready before they ever could before so
it's kind of like having early site I
think it's awesome that was I ap that
was one group fantastic work and they're
gonna be continuing that on the second
group we want to talk about is inclusive
development international now I think
listen develop an international or IDI
they're basically focused on following
the money so whenever there's an
international development project say
you're building a mine in Ghana they
want to know all of the funders who are
the
and investors in these projects so that
if something does go wrong if there's an
unethical activity they can understand
who those funders aren't go to them say
hey did you know about this maybe we
should take some action now that's all
well and good but if you think about
what it's like to be IDI when they want
to know who all those funders are they
have to basically go out and find all
that information each time so you have
to go to each Development Bank's website
got to type in the development projects
name get that information copy it paste
it cetera it's this huge laborious human
project so what they were focusing on
this weekend was trying to figure out if
they could automate that process so
could they basically automatically
scrape this data and put it all into one
workflow so that they could have this
kind of a you know a moment's notice so
that's what they set out to do and
miraculously I didn't leave just 48
hours of this weekend they set out to do
to build 13 scrapers the team built 11
scrapers in that time that we're all
working collecting that information so
they can now scrape that information
there's a front-end that they're
building that now allows IDI to go in
and just type that project name get all
that information one-click basically go
about doing the work that they really
need to do so it's saving their time
from this human join that they're
basically doing and instead automating
it so that they can focus on the work
ahead so they're gonna be building that
out and they were really excited to say
that they could just immediately start
using this right after the weekend
that's great yeah and accountability
councils so they actually work around
amplifying the voices of communities
around the world to help protect them
from the harmful effects of
international development projects and
an example of this that's worth noting
is that they actually been working with
a series of villages in Ukraine who are
facing the harmful effects of industrial
farming where they're living with 17
million chickens houses in a series of
structures that extend as far as the eye
can see and there's actually a picture
of this on the on the next slide and so
the accountability council is actually
working with them to fight back against
the company and the development banks
that are funding them in order to
address the pollution the water scarcity
and the pesticide use that all result
from intensive animal farming and the
challenge that they posed to the data
kind community during the data dive was
you know analyze online complaints and
identify which aspects of these
complaints
determines success you know is it
something as simple as the time in which
they're filed is it the number of you
know valid issues associated with the
complaint and so they dug a little bit
deeper and they analyzed a series of
projects and data across a variety of
different websites and then consolidate
that in one website in order to analyze
that and from there they actually came
up with a series of high impact insights
one of which is actually pictured on
this slide where they noted that there
is a 50% chance or more than a 50%
chance that a complaint would become
eligible to be addressed if it has three
issues or more so that's something that
they can immediately start integrating
into their processes and consider when
filing these complaints you know if
there's if they just have to but there's
an opportunity to add a third one that
would then help to ensure the success of
that particular complaint and so it's
it's worth noting that you know at the
end of the day we're talking about real
people with real problems and this data
and this kind of work that we're doing
over you know dated I've weekend can
have immediate impact yeah and I think
it's just adding to that sometimes when
people hear these examples they're like
yeah but you know that's not like you
know scale that's not you know millions
of people affected or you know terabytes
of data analyzed sometimes it's not but
really like Elise is saying these are
people's lives that are in the affected
by this and so if accountability Council
can get three more complaints through
you know when you're that community or
that family that is looking for help
yeah getting that through versus not is
you know huge issue that's that could be
life or death so I think that's what I
hear in all of these is just that
people's lives are being saved and
helped
yeah so tangibly for this work
absolutely I think actually one of the
villages in Ukraine filing that
complaint with accountability Council
described them as one of their last
hopes Wow yeah and so I think that's
that's why we're so excited by what
we're seeing in these events is that all
these organizations are now boosting
their missions with data science and
machine learning so one of the takeaways
we see is just the shocking amount that
gets done in 48 hours you know you may
think that if you're a non-profit that
data science project has to take you
know years of
years you gotta build a team first but
we see organizations that over a few
months and then a quick weekend make a
huge progress just by getting folks
together and similarly data scientists
may think well what could I do well
there's a lot if you can make a big
difference a little bit of time and so
that's I think really exciting is that
when the right people come together in
the right way and get a lot done the
other thing though is that of course
it's not just a weekend like we're not
gonna solve every problem in a weekend
before all of that like these are
systemic endemic challenges they're
gonna take a long time but what I see in
this is that this is a catalytic moment
these are organizations that are not
just like catching up with data signs
they're visionary organizations on the
front lines of social change looking for
all the ways that they can do their job
better and from something like a weekend
event or doing some data science
projects here they're now starting this
journey into something bigger we've seen
organizations often come back from this
process able to go to their funders to
say hey we need funding for a data
science team because look at this
complaint registry or look at this look
what we can do that's cute
we see organizations going and actually
now training and some of their staff to
do data science or coming back and
articulating their data science and
machine learning problems we've already
heard that from some of these groups so
I think that's what's sort of the second
takeaway for me is not just how much
great work gets done but how it really
catalyzes these data journeys for these
organizations and it's so critical that
they get this resource because again on
the front lines of making a better world
for all of us so we want them to have
everything they can absolutely it's also
yeah I just think about it as a proof
point you know a proof point to then you
know with the nonprofit model it can be
difficult to secure resources to support
a variety of different projects and
especially when they're trying out
something new it's great to be able to
point to something that they found
successful exactly so that's great and
you know another thing just to add on to
that key takeaway on impact is the power
of collaboration so before you know
early on the presentation I discussed
data for good as a movement between
private companies and nonprofits and you
know it's something that we can see you
know take place in events like the data
dive and realizing that individuals and
companies and organizations all have
different resources and abilities and so
if you're actually able to take all that
together and combine those resources and
abilities
essentially deploy them against a
strategic project that is driven by data
you can you know really make it a change
really make a difference so that's
that's something that's really inspiring
and you know being there present at my
first day to dive is well well here
hosting it in Google in New York yeah I
saw all that come to life and it really
was an impactful experience for me and
you know I believe it was you know that
way for the volunteers as well so and
especially the nonprofit organizations
I've benefited from that I couldn't
agree more
yeah I think just adding on that for
anyone who's listening I think there's a
Burundian quote I love which is what you
do for me without me you do to me and I
think that's really important when
thinking about designing these things
and in collaboration there's not just
gonna be some tech solution that like I
could come up with in my room that's
gonna solve these problems and the
nonprofit's couldn't necessarily solve
them on their own so if you're out there
taking your own data journey I think
think about that first and foremost not
what can I build but who can I build it
with because that's really the way this
stuff gets done and I couldn't agree
more I was so heartened in the light and
seeing everyone work together and seeing
that support across you know
corporations nonprofits and everyone
working together to make some good stuff
happen absolutely so you know what can
you do come together and join the data
for good movement yeah I think I'd be
remiss not to mention that of course a
data kind we're always looking for folks
to come be involved so if your data
scientist who wants to help out come to
data kind org
and I kind of get involved we have
volunteer opportunities we've got
projects there's jobs all sorts of stuff
going on we also have meetup communities
around the world you could join so
please do that and we're also starting
to look for ways to go into issue areas
more deeply so keep an eye out we will
be having some very exciting projects
coming up very soon around that awesome
and also a note from Google cloud so
with Kaggle if you're a non-profit you
can apply to actually host one of those
online events to apply big data
solutions to your mission or real world
challenge and if you are a data
scientist analyst or whomever just
looking to learn more about data
analytics you can actually sign up to
join the cago community and get started
from there so with that thank you that's
a wrap and stay tuned for the live Q&A
you
welcome back we have the questions so
the first one how can we make data
science more accessible to the public oh
that is a great question let's see if we
have the answers so I think when I hear
this question what I think about is
things I've heard people say about the
fact that as technologists we may
understand what an algorithm can do or
what statistical bias is but for most
people like I think about my aunt my
grandma you know they're walking around
just you know clicking apps and make
having decisions made for them so I
think that a question a lot of people
wonder about is how do we help people
understand what this stuff does because
if we don't we run the risk of people
not knowing if the data's being used
unethically or not being able to engage
in it it's just being out there so I
think a couple things come to mind you
know for me basically one is webinars
like this we got to get out there and
talk about it you know you say stats or
math or data and most people's eyes
glaze over but when you say hey here's a
way that folks are using data to empower
communities or to learn about when a
development projects gonna happen sooner
they go okay I never really thought
about data that way I thought about
spreadsheets or math but that's actual
that's cool so I think we have to talk
about it more so if you're someone out
there who knows about this stuff and
shout it to the world I do also think we
probably need a little more public
literacy around data and around
algorithms you know one thing I think a
lot of people are frustrated by is the
fact that so many people seem to be
confused by what data does or or using
data to prove a political point that you
know maybe they shouldn't be making and
I think we haven't yet built a kind of
public critical thinking around data
like when you look at a newspaper
article or or a picture we've some
people have built this kind of critical
lens about how someone took that picture
right we know when we see a provocative
image we go okay well there was a
photographer they chose to take this
over something else they probably have
an agenda what's the agenda hopefully
people are thinking that way but I don't
think we're thinking that way about data
yet there you see a chart so this was me
a 45 percent people are likely to die
from smoking whatever
doesn't even make sense but I think
people go well that's fact no one thinks
well what data did we collect you're not
collect what's that persons angle and so
that's a common reason just you know
what's on the X versus Y axis and where
do the numbers start there to actually
then demonstrate a particular point
versus zooming out and looking at the
whole picture exactly there's like huge
visual literacy in total you know tricks
you can play with that and that just
takes training yeah we just have to get
people used to that so I think the more
again we can talk about it the more that
we can educate people maybe even this
will be controversial but uh replace cal
classes in public education with
statistics classes I think that might be
more relevant these days things like
that I think you're gonna be helpful but
um conversation has to start with the
folks who know it getting that out there
so mm-hmm get out there and talk more
about I think that's gonna be really
helpful yeah I think it's also important
to think about you know data science
versus science because they're not too
different when you really think about
them so you know as or like a scientist
a data scientist will you know take
observations will actually come up with
a hypothesis and then test that
hypothesis kind of using their own
scientific method against the data and
against the observations that they've
collected and then you know seek to
derive a meaningful insight from there
and I think it's also you know
rhetorically looking at the term data
thinking about you know well what what
actually comprises data you know it's a
historical record its its temperature
its the amount of sunlight or you know
rain in a particular area it's a variety
of things that's anything that can be
recorded you know if you keep your own
journal you could consider that to be
data and then you you know your own kind
of semantic analysis actually see what
are the most prevalent words that come
up in this particular year or something
within your journals so really data can
be everything or anything and everything
and it doesn't have to just be this kind
of you know idea of you know binary
totally so totally and I'm so sorry
before I move on to the next question
there's just one last thing I want to
add here which is that as data scientist
one of the things that we can do is just
share out how we're doing what we do
data kind one of our values we believe
very strongly in that we train everyone
on is transparency the idea is that if
you are clear about what assumptions you
make how you're using that data what
that data is what you're trying to do
that's going to go a long way to people
standing what goes on well let's face it
there's some not-so-great things going
on in the the image of tech these days
one of the best ways to combat that is
to just be open about what we're doing I
think that's gonna help demystify a lot
of this stuff I think demystifies oh
really yeah no good term to think about
and so on the next question what is the
role of data science your opinion and
the humanitarian sector especially given
your work with data kind and you
founding the organization I love
personally to hear about you know your
kind of intention and thoughts around
this and in founding your organization
oh well thank you I would love to hear
your thoughts on this well as well
because I know you've seen a lot of data
for humanitarian work look I I think it
actually comes back to what is the role
of data science first and foremost like
you said it's like science you're
getting information you're able to not
just look in the past now but sometimes
predict the future that's a pretty new
human ability its scale is so much more
data that allows us to do that and of
course so many more things that we can
automate went like we said in the
webinar how many people man hours or
person hours excuse me hours are spent
just typing things into a computer
collecting that information when you
could be out actually solving problems
so that's the kind of stuff I think data
science machine learning is great for so
why is that different in the
humanitarian sector I think it's
actually not that much different I think
anywhere someone has a a clear thing
that they're working on to get more
people into homeless shelters to you
know speed up transportation to Franklin
global warming all that stuff there's
opportunities to learn from the past the
data predict what might happen in the
future with data and automate those
processes so I think that opportunity is
everywhere and that really ties back to
your question about how we started the
organization you know at the risk of
sounding a little grandiose it almost
felt immoral for lack of a better word
that we could have this wonderful
technology that could teach us so much
more about our futures and automate what
we do and not apply it for social good
there wasn't a world where we were
seeing this make the world a little bit
better than what are we really doing so
I think that's to me what's so exciting
about this is
the whole Big Data revolution has put
this opportunity in the hands of pretty
much well but many more people across
the globe than ever before so I think
the opportunities are endless I think
whether it's the kind of big lighthouse
projects that you see out there that
seem really cool like using satellite
imagery to track poverty estimates which
you see the World Bank and others doing
today even just the mundane seemingly
mundane stuff like optimizing someone's
workflow so they don't have to fill
something out by hand all those things
are resulting in the world being better
thanks to data science that's what I see
I'm here's what are you seeing similar
things or where do you see they're wrong
yeah I'd say that it's important to
think about data analytics and data
science as a tool and as a method right
so I was actually just thinking about
you know surveys like qualitative
surveys and that's something that is
also a method that you know nonprofit
organizations companies whomever can
also employ but it doesn't I mean what
are you gonna do with a qualitative
sorry if you don't have essentially the
underlying foundation what we're trying
to learn from that survey so you know
with that being said I mean you can you
can think about data analytics and
machine learning in the same way so what
is this going back to this idea of you
know data science similar to science
like what is the fundamental question
that you're trying to solve you know
what is the you know where's the
potential data analytics here to help
you solve that and how can you aggregate
organize synthesize data in order to
help you achieve that so you know
something actually heard from the
nonprofit participants in the data dive
as well is really you know the power of
data but also understanding that you
know it is something that needs a firm
and guiding hand do you need to have
that intention behind it because also to
your point from what you're saying
before around you know essentially data
science and while the reality that you
know you have to have that underlying
intention that underlying you know
insight into something in order to
actually bring something to life start
with a question not the data I can't
remember who we ripped that off from but
it's on all our walls at the company cuz
yeah it's you gotta know what you're
trying to do and then this is in service
of it I think that's a great point yeah
absolutely so again having that kind of
you know that guidance at hand also
understanding developing the
understanding
and the nuances of using these kinds of
tools can't agree more
mm-hmm next question
so what skills are needed to take part
in the data for good movement when you
look for in your volunteers Oh such a
great question I think when people hear
this they think oh so I've got to be
some you know Aix permission learning
engineer and yes there's a place for
that that's we definitely need that but
when I actually think about what the
hardest parts of this work are it's
really around communication and
collaboration
so I'm imagine this okay if you're a
data scientist you probably do work for
your company and they have data that
comes in through infrastructure and QA
and you've got business objectives and
you can just kind of get in there and
tweak things optimize build some models
on some nice clean data now imagine that
you're thrust into a nonprofit
organization that does not have that
data infrastructure where they cannot
necessarily articulate their data
science problem where all of them you've
got you know ethical factors waiting in
you've got people who have tons of
different constraints on them the skills
you start to need are skills like being
able to hear someone's requests and
really understand what the underlying
need is the REDCROSS project that we
spoke about before is actually a good
example so when I first came to them one
of their teams the question was how do
we upgrade our databases you know that's
our data problem and sure the Stata base
is probably needed to be upgraded could
have done that but it took some data
scientists with a smart analytical
mindset to step back and to your point
ask the question not start with a
question not the data and so what were
you trying to do and that's how they
eventually got to this idea that what
we're trying to prevent fires we need to
put the smoke alarm somewhere well how
do you do that we're not sure that's how
they found the data science problem so I
would say that's actually really some of
the most critical skills whether with
data kind or anyone else in the data for
good movement that are needed being able
to hear a problem and understand what
the solution could be to come at a
problem with humility to realize that we
may know technology but that's it I mean
these other people know the the space
their issue area the people involved you
know to come in and not think I've got
the solution but instead say hey maybe I
could be some support possibly I think
that humility is a big role and then
being able to communicate across all the
technologists and non tech
I think those are huge so I would say as
much as the work we do is around tech
and we need expert technologists those
other kind of critical thinking and
collaborative communication skills are
almost worth more
so I'd say bring those and also if
you're feeling like we have but what if
I'm not in that boat either hey don't
worry this whole thing is a big pro bono
operation we need people who are project
managers communications experts you know
the UX designers there's a role for
almost anyone in this movement because
again it touches all of us it's an it's
we're shaping society together so really
there's room for everyone yeah
absolutely and I think so you said
something I was thinking about myself
it's just critical thinking being a
critical thinker so having you know you
don't necessarily need even though we
are talking about technology we are
talking about data analytics and science
you don't necessarily need to have a
technical background of really any kind
to participate as long as you cuz you're
gonna mention before you know this
consulting decision being a having
consulting experience or something could
absolutely be useful totally all those
management consultant frameworks does
everyone laughs I think they're really
useful for getting people to think
through a problem that's where you have
to start to get this stuff right yeah
and also I'd say research experience so
if you have conducted any qualitative or
quantitative research outside of you
know data science that something can
also employ the ability to synthesize
large amounts of information especially
if they're provided by you know said
nonprofit organizations so you can then
you know parse out those individual
questions that we were talking about
before they're critical for data science
I'd say that's you know also something
that is a very useful skill in the data
for good movement and also design so
increasingly data visualizations are
very important to expressing you know
data because if you think about it you
know as as an average you know person or
consumer if a scientific report comes
out you know that's not necessarily
reaching you and if it is reaching you
it's often distilled in a series of ways
right and similarly a you know data
analysis can then be you know achieved
or you know published in a certain way
within kind of a niche group but it's
not necessarily reaching you know the
average person so with that being said
data visualization actually comes into
play there that's incredibly useful to
synthesize information that's something
you can actually do a data studio on the
Google cloud size you know side which
connects to Google bigquery where you
could for example
analyze the GCP public datasets they're
available as I mentioned before from the
World Bank EPA NOAA etc and then
visualize that information explore see
what you can find in data studio because
that helps to drive action you have a
dashboard you have these clean charts
and maps and really whatever you'd like
to customize from there and you can
share it with others very cool maybe
time for one more you gonna try to do
both lightning let's see maybe you won't
try both later all right let's go been
watching on so next question where can
data science make the most impact oh
this is a great question people always
ask what's the issue area to go into
step one I'd say there's almost no limit
right because as we mentioned data
science can help with all you know
seeing the future and automating and you
can use that everywhere I will say I
think we see great opportunities
wherever there's a really kind of
quantifiable outcome that everyone's
agreed on so your health outcomes like
eliminating a disease food transport
water those are a little easier than
some of the more like human rights
advocacy level kind of projects but
there's still opportunity there too but
I think maybe one of the ways I'm going
to spend this even in the lightning
round is you know what considerations
you have to think of in different issue
areas because remember places that are
working for human rights data has been
used as a weapon against them we need to
get data about vulnerable communities
governments use that against folks so
there's still great room for data
science to be used but you got to go
about in a totally different way there
has to be a huge lens on privacy ethics
and consideration you really have to
work through those groups understand how
to protect these communities so maybe
that's what I would say is there's room
everywhere for it there's so many
opportunities but you might have to take
a slightly different tack in each of the
different areas yeah I'd say quickly I
think that a huge opportunity for you
know data science and analytics is the
environment that's something that you
know you can see mentioned before World
Bank and satellite imagery well
satellite imagery can also be used to
for example track deforestation in the
Amazon or in other highly biodiverse
regions it's something that Google Earth
outreach has been working on with
different indigenous organizations and
protecting their ancestral lands and
that's something that data analytics
analysis GIS that all can be supremely
helpful nice
and last question yes 1 ok so how did
data kind select their engagement models
and what's next next ok let's think of
it this way the whole purpose of this
organization is to see data science
applied to any social challenge where it
could be useful and so we picked
engagement models that could tap into
existing talent and just kind of sew it
together as easy as possible we laugh we
often say where the Weaver of worlds
like we don't have a lot of
technologists on staff because most of
our job is just coordinating experts in
the social sector and technology to come
together to do great things so we pick
them that way to try to make sure that
people have the least overhead to
helping from either side as they want to
and I so when you ask what's next all I
could think of is we're working to scale
that out so we want to know if you're
out there and you want to build a data
kind community on your own let us know
we're working with some exciting news
coming out we're working with the
foundation to be thinking in the next
few months about how we can grow out and
replicate this model so I would
basically just leave this as an open
call to people to say if you're a
corporation an University nonprofit
anyone else who wants to see more data
for good in the world wants to think
about how to scale it come talk to us
come to data Condor good write us an
email because now we've got some big
plans there and love you all be a part
of it and you also have several chapters
we do we involved your chat around the
world yeah we've been learning from the
five we have there in places that are
rich in both nonprofits in tech but we
want to take it beyond that how do we
get this in every city every
organization that wants it so again if
you have ideas on that come talk with us
that's great well thank you so much for
your time for joining me here in the New
York office thank you Bob's is really
great just talking about the data dive
and the work that we were able to you
know do together and so we're actually
at time for this webinar so that being
said would like to thank you all out
there as well and say stay tuned for the
next session because what's coming up
next is accelerating insights with
external data sets on GCP thanks again
thanks
you